I say the word amphetamine and you’re probably
picturing some illegal powder in a white baggie,
right?
What if I told you they come in a little labeled
orange bottle too?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
You probably know of amphetamines in their
popular form as a medications for ADHD like
Ritalin and Vyvanse.
But amphetamine use isn’t a new phenomenon.
It’s usage can be traced back over a century;
it was first synthesized in 1887 and used
to treat asthma.
But in WWII, soldiers on either side of the
war took amphetamines to stay alert and be
more efficient.
Today, college kids cramming for tests and
manual laborers pop these pills for pretty
much that same reason.
Amphetamine is considered a schedule 2 drug
here in the states, meaning that while it’s
used as medication, it has a high potential
for abuse.
And studies show that more and more students
use and abuse amphetamine to work harder,
faster and longer.
But at what cost?
According to a study published in the journal
Brain Behavior, misuse of ADHD stimulants
has dramatically increased over recent years.
So called “the good grade pill”, these
schedule 2 drugs are standing in for a study
buddy.
They’re stimulants which help kids with
ADHD reduce impulsivity and focus.
But for those without the condition, it’s
reported that it boosts energy levels and
increases motivation and focus.
So students use them when studying, like for
pull-all nighters.
For schedule 2 drugs, they’re almost too
easy enough to get.
According to one report from pharmaceutical
supplier Express Scripts, 4.8 million Americans
have a prescription for ADHD medication.
Plenty more get their hands on the drugs through
friends, colleagues, and classmates.
Willy Pedersen, Professor Sociology at the
University of Oslo called amphetamines “a
hazardous substance that is often used by
ordinary people.”
According to a study published in the journal
Nature, amphetamine affects the brain by disrupting
the functioning of a dopamine transporter.
As more of these chemicals are released and
their reuptake is blocked by the drug, more
dopamine floats freely in the brain.
But according to another study published in
the journal Biological Psychiatry, the clinical
benefits of cognitive enhancement get outstripped
by other less medically desirable effects
like addiction and a study published in the
journal Brain Behavior states other risks
like psychosis, heart problems, and even sudden
death.
And one study published in the American Heart
Journal found that young adults who abuse
amphetamines have a greater risk of getting
a tear in the main artery leading to the heart.
Another study, published in The International
Journal of Neuropsychopharmacology, found
that long term amphetamine use can lead to
permanent changes in the brain.
The researchers found that long term use causes
chemical imbalances in the brains of mice.
And imbalances of these brain chemicals like
serotonin, dopamine and nor-ep-in-ephrine,
are associated with mental health disorders
like depression and addiction.
According to a study published in the journal
Seminars in Neuroscience, since amphetamines
work on dopamine in the brain, they are habit
forming.
Addiction happens slowly as you build up a
tolerance.
People will have to use more of the drug to
get the same cognitive boost.
While doctors might prescribe doses as low
as 10 mg, some students take several doses
in a row, as high as 400 mg at one time, which
can cause hallucinations, seizures, and often
hospitalization.
And these kinds of instances are on the rise.
A 2013 report by the federal Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services Administration
says ER visits from “nonmedical use” of
these kinds of drugs among young adults tripled
from 2005 to 2011.
So while many kids take these study buddies
“just like vitamins”, amphetamines can
have profound and devastating effects when
taken incorrectly.
So if you feel like you’re struggling in
school, maybe talk to your doctor about it
first, instead of your lockermate.
Think abusing amphetamines is cool?
Guess who else abused them.
Nazis.
Yeah and ISIS.
Not so cool now eh?
Head over to TestTube News to learn more how
amphetamines help soldiers deal with the chaos
of war.